الزمان اغسطس
1999 المكان ولايه ازميت بتركيا الحدث
زلزال بقوه سبع درجات فاصله سته على مقياس
ريختر هز البلاد 45 ثانيه خلفت اكثر من 17
الف قتيل وما يقدر بنحو 500 الف شخص
درس قاسم اجراءات كثيره اتخذت لتفادي
تكرار الكابوس في بلد اراد قدره الجغرافي
ان يكون بلد زلازل قوانين ولوائح بناء
جديده ابرزها فرض تحديث البنيه التحتيه
لتكون اكثر مقاومه للزلازل وفرض ضريبه
الزلزال للاستعداد للاسوء لكن اليوم
وبعدما تكرر السيناريو اصوات تتساءل عن
اموال ضريبه الزلازل وفيما استثمرت
ينتقدون عفوا عن البناء غير القانوني
مقابل دفع غرامه محدده قدمته الحكومه
التركيه
اتهامات بالمقابل تطالب البلديات
والمقاولين بالاهمال القاتل السلطات لاحقت
واعتقلت العشرات من المقاولين بعد الزلزال
ومنعت اخرين من السفر
للتحقيق معهم